[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to our
Channel today we're embarking on an
exciting and colorful journey into the
world of fresh and delicious peaches
from the vast Peach orchards in the
United States to Modern processing
facilities we will explore every step of
the peach growing harvesting and
processing process get ready to witness
the large-scale operations and precision
of the peach farming industry in the US
whether you are a fan of Agriculture a
peach Enthusiast or simply curious about
where your food comes from this video
will provide you with interesting
insights into peaches and a greater
appreciation for the hard work of the
farmers don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button and join us as we
discover how Farmers grow Harvest and
process peaches We Begin our journey in
the vast Peach Orchards across the US
peaches are not only a beloved fruit but
also an important part of American
agriculture every year the US produces
around 620,000 tons of peaches with
States like California Georgia and New
Jersey leading the way California is the
largest producer accounting for 81% of
the nation's Peach production at
American Farms peach trees are usually
planted in late winter or early spring
the process begins with selecting the
right Peach varieties and preparing the
soil with optimal pH levels peaches
require well- drained soil and
meticulous care to ensure healthy growth
although these peach trees are only one
year old they promise fruitful harvest
in the future most Peach varieties take
three years or more to Bear their first
fruit caring for peach trees is a
crucial part of the process the trees
are pruned at the top to direct
nutrients to the roots and trunk
promoting strong growth pruning is an
important step to ensure sunlight can
penetrate the canopy efficiently
managing water especially during the
ripening stage when Peach blossoms are
in full bloom Farmers carefully prune
the trees leaving about 60% of the
blossoms to ensure optimal fruit density
and enhance Peach quality in Peach
Orchards millions of honeybees are
brought in to assist with pollination
after pollination Farmers assess fruit
density and remove excess fruits to
maintain the best quality peaches are
typically harvested in late February and
early March for Orchards with multiple
Peach varieties the harvest season
usually lasts about 2 weeks with several
picking
to ensure the peaches are harvested at
Peak ripeness preserving the best
quality and flavor most Farms choose to
harvest peaches by hand a process that
is carried out with great care and
precision Farmers usually Begin work
early in the morning when the weather is
still cool they gently hold the peach
and twist it slightly to detach it from
the branch without damaging the tree or
the fruit the peaches are then placed
carefully into baskets or bins to avoid
bruising next the peaches are sorted
into baskets or bins to ensure that none
are damaged during the Harvest at the
packing facilities farmers use
specialized scales to weigh multiple
peaches at once these scales are
designed with several compartments where
the peaches are sorted by weight before
being transferred into the appropriate
bins based on size thousands of workers
from Mexico and Guatemala come to help
with the peach Harvest each worker can
prune about 12 Trees in just 30 minutes
and earns an average of $13 per hour
peaches are hand harvested each year by
about 5,300 workers with wages ranging
from $1 11 to $16 per
[Music]
hour at Large Scale processing
facilities peaches undergo several steps
to ensure the best quality after being
harvested peaches are cooled to remove
field heat helping to slow the ripening
process and preserve freshness the
peaches then go through inspection and
washing to remove dirt and pesticide
residues here they undergo a meticulous
process to become various products first
the peaches are sorted by size and
quality the best peaches are blanched in
hot water to soften the Skins making
them easier to peel without damaging the
flesh after peeling the peaches are
sliced and pitted in preparation for
their final products such as canned
peaches and syrup dried peaches for
long-term storage or Peach puree for
juice or baby food thank you for joining
us on this journey to discover the
process of growing and harvesting
peaches we hope you now have a deeper
understanding of the dedication and
effort of the farmers if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more
interesting content from our Channel
don't forget to hit the Subscribe button
and turn on notifications so you won't
miss any future videos leave a comment
below and share your experiences with
peaches see you in the next video
[Music]